mais mes chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs madame la rapporteur nous
poursuivons aujourd'hui nos travaux par
une audition conjointe des représentants
de plusieurs cabinets de conseils nous
vous remercions Madame Monsieur de vous
êtes mobilisés pour cette audition
son titre le formulaire notre commission
d'enquête en temps recherché les liens
entre les phénomènes de pénurie de
médicaments qui affectent de manière
croissante la prise en charge des
patients en France et les choix
industriels réalisés par les entreprises
pharmaceutiques ces dernières décennies
à cette égard il nous semble que
plusieurs tendances de fonds peuvent
être distinguées sur lesquels nous
souhaitons nous souhaiterons bénéficier
de votre éclairage d'abord le secteur
est marqué par une importante
spécialisation des grandes entreprises
de pharmaceutiques à la faveur de
plusieurs vagues de cession ou de fusion
celle-ci ont eu tendance à recentrer
leurs activités sur certaines aires
thérapeutiques
rémunératrice ou certaines étapes du
processus de production des médicaments
les activités chimiques et en
particulier la production de principes
actifs des spécialités matures ont été
singulièrement touchées par ce mouvement
d'externalisation
par ailleurs le secteur a connu ces
dernières années de nombreuses vagues de
délocalisation la concentration de la
fabrication de principes actifs en Asie
en particulier a souvent été mentionné
durant nos auditions comme un facteur
important de fragmentation des chaînes
d'approvisionnement et pour la France de
perte de souveraineté l'industrie
française apparaît à cet égard
particulièrement touché auparavant
leader notre pays n'occupe plus que la
quatrième place en Europe en matière de
production de médicaments et le nombre
d'entreprises impliquées y a été divisé
par deux depuis 40 ans
enfin les prix très élevés obtenus des
régulateurs ont encouragé les grandes
entreprises pharmaceutiques à
privilégier le développement et la
production de produits innovants on
atteint parfois des sommets éthiquement
contestables au détriment de produits
matures pourtant indispensables à la
prise en charge des patients qui eux ont
connu par contre une baisse drastique de
leur prix ce sont ces produits qui en
infectiologie comme en cancérologie par
exemple et dans de nombreuses ères
thérapeutiques concentrent l'essentiel
et difficulté d'approvisionnement
observer ces dernières années et que
nous vivons complètement actuellement
même pour les certains traitements
cancérologiques
parce que vous avez été amené à
conseiller les entreprises
pharmaceutiques dans leur choix
stratégiques et plus largement à
analyser pour vos clients ce secteur
d'activité nous souhaiterons bénéficier
de votre éclairage sur l'ensemble de ces
stratégies industrielles votre audition
doit permettre à la commission d'enquête
de revenir à l'origine des constats et
des inclinaisons stratégiques opérées
par les entreprises pharmaceutiques ces
dernières décennies
vous pourrez nous dire dans quelle
mesure ces choix on contribue si on veut
à fragiliser les chaînes de production
et aggraver les phénomènes de pénurie de
manière plus prospective vous pourrez
également nous indiquer dans quelle
mesure une relocalisation en France et
en Europe d'une partie des capacités de
production aujourd'hui absentes vous
paraît possible des souhaitable et nous
pensons évidemment beaucoup à la
question de l'industrie chimique son
présent autour de la table Monsieur
Thomas London directeur associé au
bureau de Paris de McKinsey et compagnie
et responsable pour la France des
activités santé publique Monsieur
Olivier vierzba Directeur Associé
seigneur du Bones Boston Consulting
Group en charge du soin
messieurs Laurent Benarous et Julien
Gauthier Directeur Associé associé senor
de Roland Berger Paris monsieur Loïc
Plantevin et Madame Laurent siaponi
associé à senior et directrice marketing
au sein de Ben et compagnie et enfin
Monsieur Jean-François Lopez Directeur
Associé DEC partners
je vais vous céder madame messieurs la
parole tour à tour pour un propos
introductif bref de 5 minutes et je
couperai si ça dépasse les 5 minutes
compte tenu du nombre important de
présents autour de cette audition puis
madame Laurence Cohen rapporteur de
notre commission d'enquête vous posera
une première série de questions comme
vous l'aurez compris notre commission
d'enquête on peut obtenir des réponses
étayées à des questions précises que
nous ne manquerons pas d'ailleurs de
faire suivre de répondre écrite si
nécessaire j'incite que j'indique que
cette audition est diffusée en direct
sur les sites internet du Sénat et
qu'elle fera l'objet d'un compte rendu
détaillé publié avant de vous donner la
parole je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête et passible des peines prévues
aux articles
434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je
vous invite chacun à votre tour à
activer votre micro et prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
en levant la main droite et en disant je
le jure monsieur Lopez
monsieur plantain
je le jure monsieur vierza
je le jure monsieur Gauthier monsieur
benar
je vous remercie et je vous donne la
parole dans l'ordre
bonjour
[Musique]
donc Jean-François Lopez
je le jure voilà je vous remercie voilà
Monsieur Lopez excusez-moi donc
certainement un nom que vous connaissez
moins que les autres compagnies ici
présentes
on est effectivement on fait du Conseil
spécifiquement pour des industriels de
la santé c'est notre cœur d'activité on
est une société qui est relativement
restreinte en termes de nombre de
personnes parce qu'on est 30 35 mais
spécifiquement dédié à la santé on n'a
pas d'autre cœur d'activités que que le
domaine de la santé et dans le cas de
ces activités on aide nos clients en
fait à comprendre
l'environnement dans lequel ils sont
parce que des fois il peut être un peu
obscur pour eux notamment au regard de
ces évolutions et de ses évolutions
rapides un environnement dans lequel ils
aimeraient rentrer que ce soit en terme
géographique ou en termes d'air
thérapeutique et dans ce cadre là on est
en rapport des supports en fait de
réflexion de conseils et de
recommandations on regarde de leur
organisation
de l'intérêt potentiel des produits
qu'ils ont qu'ils aimeraient amener sur
le marché
et
ensuite libre à eux de suivre pas les
recommandations qu'on leur formule moi
pour ma part je m'occupe plus
particulièrement en fait des tout ce qui
est des procédures d'accès au marché ou
ce qui est évaluation du médicament
notamment par la chaise donc ce qui
donne lieu en fait vous avez
transparence et ensuite procédure de
négociation du prix ou de renégociation
du prix ou de ronégociation du prix
parce que comme je pense que vous le
savez en fait les prix en France sont
extrêmement régulés et de Lyon en fait à
des vagues de réévaluation ou
rediscution assez fréquentes
donc ça c'est la partie donc je m'occupe
plus spécifiquement alors peut-être
aussi pour préciser on ne fait pas de
conseils en politique industrielle où
en cas on va dire en question logistique
d'usine ou de complexe industriel c'est
une partie qu'on ne gère pas qui ne
partie très spécifique donc je ne serai
pas en mesure de pouvoir répondre à des
questions qui touchent à la chaîne de
production et son organisation voilà
Conseil ont des conséquences en matière
industrielle
est un cabinet de conseil en stratégie
créa Boston en 1973 nous sommes sur le
point de fêter nos 50 ans le bureau
parisien a été fondé en 1985 et nous
comptons à ce jour une cinquantaine
d'associés à Paris donc 4 dédié au pôle
de compétences santé
au travers de nos 65 bureaux dans 40
pays la mission de Baignes et des décès
clients dans l'accélération de leur
création de valeur qu'elle soit
économique mais également sociétal nous
accompagnons plus spécifiquement les
équipes de direction dans leur choix
stratégique et leur mise en place
en termes d'expertise nous intervenons
dans de nombreuses problématiques et en
particulier la mise en place de
stratégies globale ou transformation les
fusions et acquisitions les stratégies
d'innovation et commerciale
l'amélioration de la plateforme et la
transformation digitale
nous servons de nombreux secteurs
industriels dont bien évidemment les
acteurs de la santé et en particulier
les acteurs de la pharmacie et des
dispositifs médicaux
à titre d'exemple pour le bureau de
Paris depuis 2019 notre travail pour des
acteurs de la santé en France à
représenter une trentaine de projets sur
les 617 projets réalisés en France soit
environ 5%
plus spécifiquement pour ces acteurs de
la santé mais il n'est compagnie a
conduit des travaux en France et en
Europe en particulier sur les
problématiques de stratégiques globale
et de transformation de fusion
acquisition et de stratégies
commerciales nous sommes par ailleurs
très actifs dans le monde de
l'investissement accompagnant de
nombreux fonds dans leur transaction et
le soutien de leur société en
portefeuille
par ailleurs au delà des travaux pour
nos clients nous pour nous publions
aussi régulièrement un certain nombre de
rapports sur différents sujets par
exemple nous venons de publier en
février notre baromètre annuel du moral
des investisseurs américains sur la
France en partenariat avec l'hamecham
qui intègre dans son panel un
pourcentage significatif d'industrie de
la pharmacie d'industriels de la
pharmacie
nous sommes à votre disposition afin de
répondre au mieux à vos questions et
pouvoir apporter notre éclairage dans
les domaines de nos compétences et
d'expérience reconnaissante notre
exposition néanmoins aux problématiques
propres des pénuries et très limité
merci
vous remercie de répondre à nos
questions madame monsieur Vierzon
[Musique]
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs bonjour à tous et merci de
nous recevoir aujourd'hui je suis
Olivier Vierzon directeur associé du
Boston Consulting Group en charge
notamment d'animer notre centre
d'expertise santé en France cette
question des pénuries de médicaments
particulièrement critique plus récemment
cet hiver est un sujet de préoccupation
majeur des Français et nous sommes très
sensibles au travail de cette commission
pour identifier les causes et les
solutions concrètes pour y remédier je
peux par ailleurs vous confirmer que
dans les discussions que nous avons avec
nos clients ce sujet comme celui de la
sécurisation des chaînes
d'approvisionnement ou encore celui des
investissements industriels étant haut
de l'agenda des dirigeants des
entreprises pharmaceutiques
dans ce propos permettez-moi de vous
présenter brièvement le BCG et notre
activité dans le secteur pharmaceutique
le BCG est un cabinet de conseil
international détenu par ses associés
présents dans près de 60 pays dans le
monde en France nous fêtons cette année
nos 50 ans et nous employons environ
1200 personnes la quasi-totalité de nos
clients servis en France sont des
entreprises françaises le cœur de notre
activité concerne le conseil en
stratégie à destination de grandes et
moyennes entreprises et de leurs
dirigeants que nous accompagnons dans
leur transformation notamment digitale
ou environnementales nous apportons à
nos clients un accompagnement en amont
et en aval de la prise de décision en
amont il s'agit d'aider à l'éclairage de
décision par exemple en cas d'enjeu
d'investissement significatif
en aval nous accompagnons la mise en
oeuvre de ces décisions pour gagner en
vitesse et en impact
pour cela nous disposons au sein du BCG
d'une triple expertise une expertise
sectorielle dans différents secteurs de
l'économie la santé bien évidemment
l'automobile l'agrand distribution par
exemple d'autre part une expertise
fonctionnelle c'est à dire une expertise
technique pointue très spécifique j'en
cite trois ressources humaines
opérations en jeu environnementaux enfin
une expertise technologique nous
disposons d'une entité dédiée à la
technologie et l'intelligence
artificielle qui aide nos clients à
développer et mettre en œuvre des
solutions digitales
concernant notre activité dans le
secteur pharmaceutique BCG en France a
développé un peu d'expertise qui
travaille avec les grandes et moyennes
entreprises françaises du secteur depuis
de nombreuses années
nous intervenons sur des enjeux
stratégiques comme par exemple
l'évaluation d'acquisition potentiel
pour des clients qui souhaitent se
renforcer sur certains domaines
d'activités nous travaillons également
sur des problématiques opérationnels
comme par exemple l'amélioration des
chaînes logistiques pour garantir plus
de rapidité ou un meilleur niveau de
service enfin sur des problématiques
technologiques comme par exemple
l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle visant à accélérer le
développement de nouveaux médicaments
nous investissons du temps et des
ressources sur des problématiques qui
nous semblent importantes pour le futur
et la compétitivité de la France au sein
de l'industrie pharmaceutique par
exemple en travaillant identifier les
freins qui existent en France pour les
clients du secteur des biotechnologies
qui est aujourd'hui moins compétitif que
celui de nos voisins allemands belges ou
anglais ces analyses font l'objet de
rapports publics
je conclurai en disant que toutes les
équipes du BCG en France sont
particulièrement engagés à défendre la
compétitivité d'économie française
de nos entreprises et la
réindustrialisation du pays nous ne
croyons pas en une France sans usine
sans capacité de production dès 2016
nous avions choisi d'investir à Saclay
sur une usine pilote dans le seul but de
montrer à nos clients que les
technologies permettaient de relocaliser
des activités en France notamment des
unités de production plus petites plus
agiles et plus respectueuse de
l'environnement c'est souhaitable pour
des questions à la fois d'emploi de
souveraineté et de compétitivité durable
de notre pays depuis nous avons
contribué au débat public de façon
active au travers de plusieurs rapports
sur la compétitivité ou la
réindustrialisation de la France nous
pourrons y revenir si vous le souhaitez
je vous remercie pour votre écoute
merci beaucoup monsieur London
merci bonjour madame la présidente
Madame la rapporteur mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs je
vous remercie de cette opportunité de
venir apporter quelques éclairages sur
les enjeux liés aux pénurie de
médicaments je suis responsable des
activités santé publique et secteur
public de McKinsey et évidemment à titre
là cette problématique et est essentiel
puisqu'elle revêt des enjeux clés en
matière de santé publique justement et
de capacité de notre système de santé à
répondre efficacement aux besoins des
Français y compris en cas de crise ou de
ou de perturbation forte
en préparation de cette audition et
aussi en préparation de la réponse à
votre demande d'information nous sommes
encore en train de collecter un centre
d'éléments pour pour revenir vers vous
je tâcherai d'apporter autant de
précisions possibles en réponse à vos
questions même si à titre personnel je
ne travaille pas je n'interviens pas sur
ces sujets d'organisation de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement auprès des
industriels et si nécessaire nous
pourrons éventuellement apporter
d'ailleurs des compléments de réponse
par écrit lorsque vous le jugerez
nécessaire
parmi les missions de notre cabinet les
enjeux industriels constituent une
dimension importante sur laquelle nous
accompagnons un grand nombre d'acteurs
dans tous les secteurs dont certains
acteurs du domaine pharmaceutique
et en matière industrielle en France
nous travaillons avec prioritairement
sur des problématiques de renforcement
de leur base industrielle
en particulier le développement des
capacités de production
l'amélioration de la compétitivité des
sites qui permettent consolider leur
position et contribuer ainsi à leur
maintien sur le sol français et puis des
enjeux comme la réduction de l'empreinte
environnementale le long de la chaîne de
d'approvisionnement ou encore beaucoup
de travaux sur l'amélioration et le
renforcement des processus d'innovation
alors peut-être pour importer déjà
quelques éléments de réflexion sur la
thématique de la de la de la commission
elle me semble couvrir deux grands
aspects qui sont à la fois connexes et
distincts d'abord la sécurité de
l'approvisionnement et ensuite une
question qui a été beaucoup débattue
lors des audiences qui est celle de la
désindustrialisation éventuelle de la
France
peut-être en termes de résilience de la
chaîne
d'approvisionnement quelques quelques
réflexions d'abord la pénurie de
médicament ne constitue pas une
problématique Franco française
et elle touche un grand nombre de pays
industrialisés
les phénomènes sont assez contrastés
entre les pays et ne touchent pas
forcément d'ailleurs les mêmes
médicaments sur les pays il me semble
que l'Italie ou l'Allemagne par exemple
ont eu des pénuries récentes sur
l'ibuprofène donc premier élément on
n'est pas sur il n'y a pas une exception
française de ce point de vue là
deuxièmement les causes sont
multifactorielles et les sources de
vulnérabilité et de fragilité
peuvent se situer sur différentes étapes
de la chaîne et varie d'ailleurs d'un
produit à l'autre
il y a eu pas mal d'éléments qui ont été
abordés lors des encore une fois des
auditions précédentes donc j'y
reviendrai peut-être pas là mais
peut-être qu'on pourrait revenir et
évidemment la pandémie de covid-19 a eu
un effet aggravateur en perturbant les
chaînes d'approvisionnement de multiples
de multiples manières et aujourd'hui les
chaînes d'approvisionnement n'ont pas
encore retrouvé complètement le point
d'équilibre d'un van covid
sur le deuxième sujet celui de la
localisation de la production sur le sol
français
peut-être deux points en introduction
d'abord ce sujet de des
industrialisations n'est pas propre à
l'indusif pharmaceutique
et n'est pas non plus un phénomène
récent malheureusement la France a perdu
depuis 30 ans
a fait face à une dizaine du radiation
assez forte et plus forte que dans
d'autres pays de l'OCDE la part de
l'industrie dans le PIB est passé de 19%
en 2000 à 13% actuellement et donc on
est sur malheureusement un phénomène qui
est qui n'est pas propre à l'industrie
la deuxième réflexion c'est que cet
enjeu là la production est évidemment un
composante à une composante importante
de ces enjeux-là auxquels nous sommes
très sensibles
mais en fait cet enjeu là et il va
au-delà c'est vraiment un enjeu de
comment est-ce qu'on fait en sorte de
développer la valeur ajoutée au sens du
produit intérieur brut qui est produite
sur le sur le sol français et en santé
ça passe par le soutien à innovation à
la recherche biomédicale
ça passe par le développement des
biotech et des startups ça passe par
la localisation des essais cliniques sur
le sol français ou encore d'ailleurs la
localisation de centre de décision
européen au globaux sur le sur le sens
le centre sur le sol français
acide d'ailleurs c'est intéressant de
noter que au global industrie
pharmaceutique a été créatrice d'emploi
sur la période les emplois sont passés
de peu près 78 à 96.000
sur entre 2009 et 2020 et le taux de
valeur ajoutée encore une fois au sens
du PIB et passer de 25 à 34% sur cette
période donc je pense que c'est aussi
intéressant de porter un regard là
dessus de manière un peu plus globale
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur merci de m'accueillir en
qualité d'associer de Roland burger
France fonction que j'occupe depuis 5
ans je vais m'efforcer dans ce propos
liminaire de vous présenter nos
activités en France et plus
particulièrement celle qui concerne le
secteur de la santé je tâcherai d'être
le plus clair possible dans l'exposé de
nos activités je serai naturellement à
votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions si je commence par Roland
burger Roland burger est un cabinet
d'origine européenne qui s'est implanté
en France en 1990 notre bureau parisien
compte aujourd'hui près de 300
collaborateurs
nous expertises couvrent une partie des
problématiques des directions générales
et c'est problématiques constituent le
socle de nos projets que nous réalisons
pour le compte de nos clients nos
interventions sont ciblées et des
limitées dans le temps et
systématiquement assortis d'un
engagement de résultats nous élaborons
notamment des plans et des revues
stratégiques nous réalisons des
modélisations économiques et financières
qui permettent de factualiser certains
résultats et nous menons des analyses
d'impact dans le cadre de conduite de
programme
nous intervenons dans différents
domaines les services financiers la
distribution la grande consommation le
secteur public l'énergie l'aéronautique
et les transports et bien sûr le secteur
de la santé du soin
toutes ces activités tout celles que je
viens de mentionner ont un poids
comparable dans notre portefeuille
d'activités la part des clients français
issus du secteur de la santé s'élève à
environ 10% aujourd'hui de nos activités
sur la base des 15 dernières années
d'expérience dans le conseil en secteur
de la santé roland-gargan France a
développé des méthodologies spécifiques
ou problématiques stratégiques et
opérationnelles et c'est ce que nous
proposons nos clients nous intervenons
dans une grande partie de l'écosystème
de la santé donc dans la chaîne de
valeur pharmaceutique auprès des
laboratoires auprès des fabricants des
grossistes répartiteurs et des officines
dans la chaîne de valeur des dispositifs
médicaux auprès des fabricants et de
certains distributeurs auprès des
acteurs du soin dans leurs différentes
infrastructures cabinet clinique
hôpitaux et auprès des fournisseurs de
services de l'écosystème fournisseur de
logiciel notamment
nos missions couvrent divers aspects une
grande partie de notre activité est liée
aux travaux que l'on nomme diligence
stratégique leur notamment d'activités
d'acquisition donc dans ce type de
travaux nous menons des études de marché
d'analyses de concurrence la mise des
facteurs clés de succès pour ces acteurs
notamment dans le domaine des
dispositifs médicaux cardiologie
ophtalmologie orthopédie
nous analysons également les
constitutions de chaîne de soins
à la fois dans la santé humaine mais
aussi dans la santé animale
et enfin une partie de nos actions et
nos activités s'articulent autour de
missions de développement de plan
stratégique développement d'activités
pour ces entreprises dans les typologies
clients nous accompagnons les startups
et les biotech françaises dans leur
développement notamment à
l'international pour maximiser leurs
chances de succès nous aidons nos
clients à définir des stratégies de
diversification donc investir dans
d'autres activités que les gens
activités cas et nous soutenons
également certains acteurs notamment
dispositif médicaux à capturer des
opportunités de croissance sur de
nouveaux marchés
enfin nous aidons nos entreprises
naturellement à
s'adapter aux nouveaux aux nouvelles
exigences des marchés à acquérir des
compétences clés nécessaires à la future
développement très récemment on
travaille régulièrement dans tout ce qui
est acquisition de compétences digitales
sur des nouvelles opportunités offertes
par les canaux de distribution
comme demandé nous avons préparé la
liste d'études et de notes sur les cinq
dernières années que nous tenons à votre
disposition et même si nous n'avons pas
directement travaillé sur le sujet de la
pénurie médicament je me tiens
naturellement à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions
très je vous remercie d'avoir respecté
le temps à louer on va essayer d'avoir
la même discipline rigoureuse
pour pour la suite de façon à avoir un
échange le plus fourni possible
et comme les questions sont nombreuses
voilà je passe tout de suite la parole à
la madame la rapporteur Laurence Cohen
merci madame la Présidente donc je vais
vous poser plusieurs plusieurs questions
et je vais vous demander vraiment de
répondre à chacune d'entre elles bien
évidemment
la première question vous l'avez
souligné plus ou moins chacun dans vos
propos liminaires c'est qu'effectivement
depuis une trentaine d'années il y a une
politique de délocalisation
des entreprises et notamment
pharmaceutiques mais pas que mais pour
ce qui nous intéresse on va dire
pharmaceutique délocalisations donc dans
d'autres pays pour des raisons les
auditions l'ont fait ressortir pour des
raisons de rentabilité on va dire
optimale puisque les
normes sociales et environnementales
étaient on va dire moins exigeante dans
d'autres pays que dans que en France ou
en Europe donc moi je voudrais que vous
me disiez de manière extrêmement précise
est-ce que vous en tant que donc cabinet
conseil vous avez conseillé à une
entreprise d'externalisée ou de
délocaliser de telles activités de
production et pratiquement
le corollaire on va dire à cette
question c'est que quel a été votre
appréciation sur la fiscalité pour
conseiller les délocalisations et
notamment en balance qu'elle
appréciation vous avez pu avoir sur les
aides publiques je pense notamment aussi
donc ça c'est les deux questions qui
sont du même ordre peut-être que je vais
vous laisser y répondre et j'enchaînerai
par des questions sur les prix
c'est pour ça que
la question précise réponse précise et
qui se conçoit bien s'énonce bien comme
on dit Monsieur Lopez
comme je vous l'avais dit en fait sur la
question vraiment très industrielle nous
c'est pas un de nos cœurs d'activité
néanmoins c'est quand même des sujets
qui peuvent émerger dans des discussions
avec nos clients notamment de ce que en
fait quand il y a une question
d'implantation d'un site il y a une
question de compétition entre pays donc
la question c'est comment est-ce qu'on
met en valeur les atouts qui sont ceux
de notre territoire pour les faire
valoir à la maison mère
après la question de la décision de la
maison mère et de son rationnel souvent
elle nous échappe alors après de manière
un peu pragmatique ça peut être très axé
sur la problématique fiscale et la
France a pas une aura très positive sur
le sujet notamment moi je travaille pour
beaucoup de clients
étrangers notamment américains qui a une
sorte potentiellement d'épidermie par
rapport à la complexité aux millefeuille
en fait de taxation en France notamment
quand il
vont jusqu'au bout du cheminement en se
disant bon bah si j'investis de l'argent
pour produire en France et qu'ensuite je
vais être confronté à une négociation de
prix extrêmement
dur et difficile à comprendre pour moi
et après il va y avoir un enchaînement
en fait de taxes et de contribution qui
va venir s'ajouter là dessus
je dois mettre que pour les convaincre
c'est pas forcément évident donc il y a
quand même une une sorte aussi des fois
d'image un peu préconçue sur la France
c'est compliqué
moi c'est ce que je constate de
l'expérience que j'ai eu pour avoir
essayé de défendre en fait des soit des
implantations soit des extensions de
sites
en France notamment de recherche pour ma
part c'est le peu de regard que j'ai sur
le sujet
très bien merci Monsieur plante
question précise réponse précise nous
n'avons pas travaillé sur des
problématiques de délocalisation de site
industriel en France sur les 5 dernières
années nous avons travaillé sur des
problématiques de
spécialisation de sites pour répondre à
des besoins déficients
conscients que certaines de nos clients
faisaient un peu de tout partout ce qui
générait de la complexité de la perte
d'efficacité et donc on a effectivement
travaillé sur des problématiques de
comment res spécialiser des sites sur un
certain nombre de technologies de type
de produits pour draguer de l'efficience
il n'y avait aucune considération de
délocalisation
très bien
je me suis
même chose réponse question précise
réponse précise
sur les délocalisations non à ma
connaissance nous ne sommes pas
intervenus sur des sujets qui auraient
eu pour conséquence directe des
délocalisations de site industriels en
France au cours des cinq dernières
années vous avez également posé la
question de l'externalisation
et donc je mets le sujet également de
manière très précise sur la table oui
nous sommes intervenus sur un sujet qui
peut être considéré comme une
externalisation mais sur laquelle on
pourra revenir qui est que nous avons
travaillé en amont de la création
d'euros API puis ensuite en aval sur la
mise en oeuvre de roapi voilà
deux trois éléments également très
précis de notre côté comme je vous le
disais la focalisation de nos travaux
pour l'industrie sur les problématiques
de manufacturing en France et vraiment
focaliser sur ces notions de
renforcement de la base industriel de
développement des capacités de
production d'amélioration de la
compétitivité et du positionnement de
ces sites en France ce qui contribue à
leur maintien en France donc ça c'est
premier élément deuxième élément à ma
connaissance et dans l'état de
l'avancement de notre collègue de
données qui est déjà bien avancé nous
n'avons pas accompagné de projets de
délocalisation ou de fermeture ou
d'exernalisation de sites en France
ça peut être un effet connexe
le propos de mes collègues
nous ne sommes pas intervenus
directement dans ces enjeux de
délocalisation et de l'industrialisation
malgré tout
nous avons travaillé sur des réflexions
autour de renforcement de l'attractivité
de la France notamment dans le choix que
mentionner monsieur Lopez tout à l'heure
de cette compétition interpellie et donc
effectivement dans la prise en compte
des critères de d'investissement
industriels ou autre on a différents
thématiques qui interviennent alors vous
mentionnez à la thématique fiscale
réglementaire effectivement elle fait
partie d'une d'un environnement
économique qui sous-tende n'importe
quelle décision d'investissement c'est
une décision d'investissement qui ont
qui représente des sommes importantes
donc effectivement la question de
l'environnement réglementaire fiscal est
posée
mais à côté de celle-ci vous avez aussi
des vraies questions autour de la
capacité à créer ou avoir des emplois ou
des compétences de filières de santé
disponible dans le territoire qui permet
de rassurer en fait un investisseur ou
un laboratoire dans la capacité chorale
pays à doté l'usine de des bonnes
ressources et à permettre le bon
développement ça c'est un élément
important
mentionné tout à l'heure le millefeuille
effectivement parfois cette
surtransposition cette multitude de
complexité réglementaire pose malgré
tout de questions sur la capacité même
s'il y a des efforts qui ont été faits
une simplification qui a été fait
parfois pour certaines questions sur la
capacité du choix le troisième sujet sur
lequel la France est vraiment
relativement grandissent sont des
infrastructures la capacité
logistiquement de pouvoir transporter un
médicament sur l'ensemble du territoire
la capacité à bénéficier de soins
d'unité de soins de qualité pour pouvoir
administrer en fait les différents les
différents médicaments
et enfin il y a une problématique qui
est une problématique aussi de
d'optimisation du maillage du territoire
pour être sûr que dans la manière dont
le soin est organisé on arrive à mettre
les bons moyens aux bons endroits et
donc on a souvent été confronté en
France à cette problématique de
saupoudrage d'investissement un peu
partout après vous posez une question
très précise sur le crédit pour
recherche effectivement c'est
aujourd'hui dans l'analyse qu'on avait
pu faire un vrai outil de
différenciation de la France
et qui est un outil important dans la
capacité quel territoire aujourd'hui à
venir atterrir attirer un certain nombre
d'investissement
très bien merci
vous avez été le seul monsieur Gauthier
à répondre sur le fait que effectivement
le cire était un excellent outil je
crois que quand je vous parle de la
fiscalité il faut il faut prendre en
compte que au niveau des aides publiques
la France est numéro un donc là je l'ai
pas entendu dans vos autres propos si ma
première réflexion par rapport à mes
questions ma deuxième réflexion
s'adresse à Monsieur Plantevin est-ce
que
c'est vous enfin votre votre cabinet
conseil puisque nous avons comme vous le
savez notamment
auditionner Sanofi est-ce que c'est vous
qui avez conseillé à Sanofi de quelques
en quelque sorte réduire la voilure
aramont et Sisteron ou non justement de
la spécialisation c'est ma deuxième ma
deuxième remarque et puis quand je
parlais de délocalisation c'est quand
même
une stratégie de la France pas
d'ailleurs que de la France vous l'avez
vous l'avez noté c'est une stratégie
aussi qui s'est joué au niveau européen
vous dites non on n'a pas conseillé en
termes de délocalisation est-ce que
est-ce que dans ce que vous dites si je
comprends bien ça veut dire que vous
n'avez même pas
émis des conseils concernant des
délocalisations partielles par exemple
de technologie et de production au motif
de l'efficience parce que j'ai bien
compris
directement et on va refaire le tour
vous en profiter pour répondre aux
autres questions en même temps je vous
remercie merci Madame la rapporteur vous
comprendrez que dans une audition
publique où on citera pas le nom de nos
clients mais je vais répondre à votre
question nous n'avons pas travaillé pour
Sanofi sur cette sur ces sites que vous
évoquez là donc
non plus
sur la les problématiques de
délocalisation je vais répéter ce que je
disais précédemment
nous n'avons pas effectivement
travailler sur
de la délocalisation de sites en France
sur les cinq dernières années et donc
voilà je vais me permettre de reformuler
est-ce que dans vos conseils il y a pu y
avoir dans les conséquences une
délocalisation ou une stratégie
industrielle qui a fait que le paysage
tel qu'il était constitué a été modifiée
et donc même si vous n'avez pas donné le
conseil de délocaliser vos conseils ont
pu entraîner par la suite ces événements
là en sachant que vos clients sont des
clients inscrits dans le temps et donc
forcément l'interaction est régulière et
donc vous êtes forcément au courant de
ce qui a pu se passer même si il y a pas
d'accusation de liens directs il y a
cependant les conséquences indirectes
merci pour votre la position de votre
question donc
le
focus de notre activité en servant les
Big Pharma en particulier se concentrent
essentiellement sur leur produit
innovants ou leur nouveau produit nous
avons assez peu intervenus sur des
problématiques de produits nature et
le focus de la politique de les
délocalisation ou d'externalisation
comme l'évoquait monsieur wirsby est
plutôt sur les produits matures
donc
dans le cadre du spectre de de
d'intervention que nous avons fait pour
l'industrie pharmaceutique en France je
ne vois pas de lien direct entre les
recommandations que nous aurions pu
faire et des conséquences industrielles
de délocalisation
sur les cinq dernières années
la même manière en fait on travaille
quasiment jamais en fait sur des
produits matures sur des enjeux qui sont
liés aux produits Mathieu quand les
clients nous appellent c'est justement
pour des lancements de produits donc
c'est des nouveaux produits des
nouvelles technologies des innovations
est-ce que eux considère en tout cas
comme des innovations qui sont souvent
pas produites en France
voir ni même en Europe donc le sujet en
fait de l'outil productif tel qu'il est
ou tel qui va devenir nous c'est un
sujet qui sur lequel on interagit
quasiment jamais le seul sujet sur
lequel on peut interagir c'est sur
notamment des éléments de régulation
mais je pense que vous y viendrez après
par le comité économique qui peuvent eux
toucher des produits qui ont déjà eu une
vie ça c'est un autre sujet en fait
pour ma part non puisque c'est un moment
dans la phase du médicament ou les deux
sont l'innovation et le médicament
mature sur la fixation du prix
oui oui
je pense que ça fait partie de d'une
autre partie de l'audition monsieur
comme vous le disiez c'est très
difficile de retracer précisément mais
je pense que même indirectement je ma
connaissance je ne vois pas de choix ou
de travaux que nous ayons pu faire
stratégique qui peut avoir une
conséquence soit sur des transferts de
technologie soit sur des transferts de
volume soit sur des transferts de sites
de production que ce soit sur des
produits mature ou voir innovants
oui oui
parce que j'ai ce que j'ai posé comme
question concernant les le fait que les
aides publiques sont soit très
généreuses en France que donc ça fait
partie d'atouts
pour répondre à cette question je n'ai
pas adressé ce point-là qui est
effectivement un point important je
pense que l'attractivité de d'une
localisation industrielle dépendance un
certain nombre de facteurs comme vous
l'évoquez il y a des facteurs fiscaux
évidemment et d'aide publique comme le
comme le cire il y a des facteurs de
compétences et d'infrastructures il y a
des facteurs de prix et des facteurs de
matières premières je pense que les
choix de localisation sont effectivement
très multi dimensionnelles et qui a un
certain nombre d'atouts en France vous
citez le SIR et un certain une certaine
partie du cadre fiscal je pense que les
infrastructures également sont de bonne
qualité je pense que les compétences
techniques sont également de très bonne
qualité je pense que l'énergie
aujourd'hui c'est un élément important
est assez compétitif donc je pense qu'il
y a un certain nombre effectivement de
d'éléments positifs en France et il y a
également des éléments négatifs qui ont
été cités nombreuses reprises lors de de
vos différentes auditions donc
absolument je reconnais ce que vous
dites sur le fait qu'il y a qu'on a des
avantages importants en France
et également des désavantages sur un
certain nombre de points
je partage absolument ce qui vient
d'être dit sur les facteurs de
compétitivité de la France je pense ce
type de mécanisme peuvent absolument en
faire partie
et les notions effectivement de
disponibilités de compétences sur le sol
français et productivité aussi des sites
des sites en France etc sont des
éléments d'attractivité du territoire
français donc ça c'est premier élément
deuxième élément sur la fiscalité
nos principes nous interdisent nous
interdisons de donner des conseils à nos
clients sur des éléments fiscaux ça
n'était pas parti des
du périmètre des conseils que nous
sommes habilités à donner à nos clients
donc ça c'est deuxième élément et
troisième élément encore une fois à ma
connaissance je ne sers pas directement
les acteurs de l'industrie sur ces
sujets mais néanmoins à ma connaissance
et encore une fois sur la base de la
collecte d'informations je n'ai pas
identifié de projets qui directement ont
indirectement amen à de la délorisation
ou
du transfert de technologie
donc j'aurai la même réponse en termes
de projet sur la liste des études qu'on
a préparé en fait aujourd'hui il y a pas
de projet directement liés à ces
analyses après peut-être juste pour
mettre un peu les choses en perspective
quand on travaille sur le renforcement
de la compétitivité d'un acteur en
France effectivement il y a un certain
nombre d'arbitrage qui sont faits
aujourd'hui pour se dire où se trouve et
où comment l'acteur peut maximiser et
créer la meilleure valeur possible et
donc forcément nous nos travaux nous
conduisent généralement à aider les
acteurs à déterminer les meilleurs
poches de marché en fait pour pouvoir
être au meilleur niveau de compétitivité
pour être au bon niveau de compétitivité
naturellement à un moment il y a un
certain nombre d'arbitrages qui peuvent
être fait de manière indirecte à nouveau
qui sont des
arbitrages qui peuvent être des
arbitrages de spécialisation à un moment
pour être sûr d'être au bon niveau de
compétitivité sur les sujets les plus
importants et qui peuvent pas ricochet
un moment avoir un impact sur ce que
pourrait être des molécules moins
performantes sur un certain nombre de
sujet donc message je dirais que c'est
une évolution classique en économique
dans la mesure où quelque part les
entreprises au moment une logique de
développement d'une partie de leurs
activités
donc j'ai bien entendu que making C ne
donne pas de conseils fiscaux
j'aimerais bien savoir si les autres
cabinets en donnent et puis je suis un
petit peu dubitative on va dire parce
que on peut jouer comme ça au chat et à
la souris dans les questions pour les
repréciser ça joue un peu la montre mais
j'ai bien noté que quand même les choix
de localisation ou de rester sur le
territoire
dépend effectivement de nombreux
facteurs on n'apprend pas avec vous avec
votre audition ça a été dit tout au long
des auditions que nous avons commencé
depuis plusieurs mois puis on a une
petite culture sur le sujet on le savait
déjà mais justement
ces choix de localisation qui sont
multifactorielles
bien
il y a des il y a des atouts pour la
France et je pense qu'en tant que
cabinet conseil vous hiérarchiser les
atouts
il me semble-t-il et que parmi les
atouts que vous pouvez hiérarchiser
il me semble pas aberrant de penser
qu'il y a la notion de fiscalité
alors si c'est pour préciser ma question
parce qu'elle était floue je la précise
et on peut comme ça faire une cascade de
clarification mais je pense que c'est
important que vous alliez au bout de vos
réponses comme j'essaye de clarifier
mais mes questions si elles ne sont pas
suffisamment suffisamment clair et je
vais continuer pour que on va faire des
on va faire des des questions au moins
par deux pour permettre après à mes
collègues de pouvoir de pouvoir poser
également des questions mais j'aimerais
que vous puissiez nous dire si vous avez
conseillé en dehors des
des
industries donc et des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques est-ce que vous avez
conseillé des entités publiques
et évidemment du secteur de la santé et
ayant très à la souveraineté
sanitaire donc quand je parle d'entité
publique pour que nous soyons
extrêmement clair et que ma question
soit mieux comprises je parle à la fois
au niveau des ministères que ce soit le
ministère de la santé ou le ministère de
l'Industrie par exemple pour ne prendre
que des exemples mais pour que mon sujet
soit bien clair et bien cadré évidemment
quand je parle du ministère de la Santé
je pense aussi aux agences qui en
dépendent je vais pas tout vous les
citer mais vous les avez bien en tête
donc j'aimerais bien avoir de ce point
de vue là des réponses à mes questions
et puis est-ce que vous avez
conseillé des structures hospitalières
je pense à la PHP mais il y a pas que la
PHP il y a la PHM il y en a plein
d'autres ou des fédérations
hospitalières et y compris les centrales
chat donc sur quel point et sur quel
montant
peut-être que là mes questions sont plus
précises donc plus compréhensibles de
précision assez correcte monsieur Lopez
c'est effectivement très très précis et
là et la réponse est va être très
précise et non en fait parce que
le domaine d'activité par exemple de
conseils hospitalier
touche je pense à des cabinets qui sont
pas présents ici c'est pareil c'est des
structures qui sont très spécialisés
dans l'organisation hospitalière de
structures hospitalières en tout cas
nous on fait pas et
conseils vers des ministères non plus
donc pour être très précis pas pour ma
part en tout cas ma connaissance
ça fait de nombreuses années que Ben a
fait un choix de de passer à dire le
secteur public donc nous nous sommes pas
intervenus auprès de différentes
instances gouvernementales ou
ministériels ou d'autorité régionale on
a fait un projet en fait pour le
ministère de la Santé le ministère de
l'Industrie c'était ce qu'on appelle un
projet pro bono c'est-à-dire gratuit
pour accompagner le ministère de
l'Industrie et de la santé dans la
montée en capacité des tests covid en
préparation de confinement en avril 2020
avec une vraie conscience d'aider le
pays à sortir du confinement et il y
avait trois grands sujets le premier
c'était la montée en capacité de la
capacité à délivrer du test le deuxième
c'était concentré se concentrer sur la
sécurité d'approvisionnement d'un
certain nombre de produits absolument
critiques allant de choses très simples
telles que des écouvillants
jusqu'à l'accompagnement de société de
biotech ou startup délivrant aux
produisant des tests covid qui pouvaient
potentiellement accompagner le
gouvernement dans sa montée en capacité
en sortie en sortie de confinement
réponse également
précise autant que je peux l'activité
secteur public est une activité très
minime pour nous c'est moins de 1% de
notre chiffre d'affaires sur le secteur
de la
de la santé en service public
ce ne sont pas des projets que moi-même
je suis pour des raisons de séparation
entre nos activités privées et nos
activités publiques à ma connaissance
nous avons réalisé je crois trois
projets au cours des des cinq dernières
années et à ma connaissance également
aucun fut lié à la à la souveraineté
sanitaire voilà
pour plus de précisions de je devrais
vous vous revenir par écrit
alors en ce qui nous concerne on a un
secteur public et un secteur d'activité
en santé publique qui est substantielle
on a eu l'occasion de d'accompagner un
certain nombre d'acteurs publics on a
travaillé avec un certain nombre
d'hôpitaux publics notamment sur des
principales mens sur des sujets
d'amélioration des parcours de prise en
charge des patients d'amélioration
opérationnelle du fonctionnement des
hôpitaux on a travaillé aussi pas mal
sur des sujets d'innovation notamment au
développement d'institut hospitalo
universitaire par exemple
on a également travaillé avec un centre
d'autorité de santé
notamment sur la mise en oeuvre de la
des aspects logistique de la campagne de
vaccination
il y a quelques temps
et on a fourni d'ailleurs l'année
dernière une liste très complète de
l'ensemble des travaux qu'on a pu
effectuer dans le champ dans le champ
public
donc je serais ravi de vous le refaire
passer j'ai pas forcément tout en tête
mais de mémoire et
on pourra vous repréciser ça j'ai pas
mémoire là qu'on est vraiment travaillé
sur des sur des sujets de souveraineté
sanitaires
oui après le sujet de l'acquisition
d'enquête la souveraineté c'est une des
portes d'entrée on est bien sur la
pénurie de médicaments et là pour le
coup les questions de logistique
interviennent forcément et donc quand on
parle d'approvisionnement
il me semble que c'est lié
par Monsieur
quelle est la question spécifique à
propos éventuellement de ces voilà de
ces appuis là
au moins sur la partie qui concerne nos
activités auprès du secteur public
d'Angers la charge au sein de au
syndrome lamberger à Paris donc pour ce
qui concerne Roland bergers il y a eu
trois accompagnements sur les cinq
dernières années qui concernent la
sphère que vous évoquez le premier
concerne un inconvénient pour l'AP-HP
sur des sujets d'optimisation du
fonctionnement interne en dehors de
l'activité de santé donc l'activité de
restauration l'activité d'hébergement
l'activité de lingerie donc ça c'est un
transvaille qu'on a fait pour la PHP un
deuxième travail qui a été fait au tout
début de la prise covid en promo pour la
PHP en ami à disposition un certain
nombre de nos consultants pour aider la
PHP à des choses très simples simplement
il y avait des des appareils médicaux
qui arrivaient sur le parvis des
hôpitaux à Paris il fallait des
individus pour les aider à les
dispatcher dans le au sein de au sein
des hôpitaux donc on a on a on a
accompagné la PHP sur ce sujet sans sans
facturation et enfin un dernier projet
on a accompagné on a mis à disposition
des équipes en l'occurrence quelques
personnes une ou deux sur la durée de la
crise covid au sein du ministère de la
Santé pour les aider au sein de la
cellule de crise à gérer tout un tas de
sujets je serai bien en peine d'évoquer
là un par un mais on pourra mettre à
votre disposition les consultants qui
ont travaillé spécifiquement qui
pourront dire précisément ce qu'ils ont
fait dans le cadre de cette de cette
crise covid voilà les trois projets qui
concernent la sphère que vous évoquez
oui vous comprenez bien que à partir du
moment où vous vous intervenez au niveau
donc des entités publiques notamment les
hôpitaux et que vous êtes amené vous
avez été amené à intervenir au niveau
notamment de la crise covid vous êtes
vous avez sans doute été amené et c'est
les précisions que je souhaiterais
notamment avoir
outre celle qu'on peut avoir en notre
possession par rapport à une autre
commission d'enquête donc ça va les
informations circulent entre nous mais
c'est la notion des stocks par exemple
est-ce que vous avez été amené à
travailler sur ces questions et à
conseiller vos clients en matière en
matière de stock parce que ça c'est un
lien direct avec les pénuries les
pénuries de médicaments et puis mettez
donc cette question
un peu au chaud et j'enchaîne sur dans
le fait que plusieurs d'entre vous ont
dit qu'effectivement ils allaient nous
donner des précisions notamment sur leur
intervention concernant la fixation des
prix et
la négociation des prix des médicaments
nous avons reçu vous avez peut-être vous
l'avez peut-être vu la société
igvia et si on va sur son site on peut
voir un certain nombre de de conseils
qu'il prodigue alors à leurs clients
donc vous de quelle manière vous êtes
intervenu pour obtenir le meilleur prix
possible pour les médicaments et puis je
vais un petit peu plus loin est-ce qu'il
vous est arrivé en fait de négocier ou
de participer plus exactement
directement au négociations avec le CEPS
donc là la réponse va être oui
est-ce que ça c'est un peu mon coeur
d'activité donc pour comprendre le sujet
il y a effectivement
quand les clients viennent vers nous
pour savoir
quel pourrait être l'horizon de ce qui
pourrait se compter en France il y en a
une partie d'entre eux qui ont pas
forcément d'expertise sur le sujet donc
ils ont besoin d'un décryptage d'une
part des étapes ensuite dans un
accompagnement dans les étapes d'autres
sont présents en France peut être des
très grosses structures mais pas
forcément une pratique
répétitive et quotidienne du sujet
d'évaluation et de négociation ce sur
quoi on peut aussi nous les aider en
fait à les actualiser sur et les
pratiques et ce à quoi ils peuvent
s'attendre
donc dans ce cadre là en fait on va
d'une part les aider à pour ce qui est
des étapes d'évaluation
à présenter de manière correcte et telle
qu'elle est attendue par par la chass en
fait lors de mes clinique
et ça ça va donner lieu effectivement à
une évaluation
SMS comparateur que le comité économique
va ensuite utiliser pour
la fixation de son prix et dans la
fixation du prix il y a quand même de
composantes il y a le prix faciale donc
ce que vous voyez sur les boîtes et qui
peut des fois paraître extrêmement cher
puis à toute la face de régulation et
donc de primette et il y a une vraie
dissymétrie entre ce qu'on voit sur la
boîte et ce qui est réellement payé par
la collectivité on regarde des
régulations en fait qui se font et à
l'entrée et ensuite durant toute la vie
du produit
donc ça oui effectivement nous on a une
nos clients il y a un point important
c'est que déjà on les aide à comprendre
ils vont peut-être pas obtenir ce qui
vont en tête au départ il y a quand même
un gros travail de pédagogie notamment
pour les firmes étrangères
de leur expliquer quel est le champ des
possibles les champs des possibles en
France il est clairement délimité en
fait par l'évaluation has et ensuite les
critères sur lesquels le comité
économique se fixe pour décider du
niveau des prix et c'est très souvent
les comparateurs et le prix des
comparateurs
et là il y a forcément des désillusions
parce qu'en fait quand vous faites tout
un développement clinique dans une
maladie qui est très peu de temps
alternative thérapeutique mais votre
comparateur
c'est
je prends quelque chose de très peu cher
corticostéroïdes
la base de la négociation elle va partir
de là quand même et ça peut être un peu
déceptif quand même et donc mieux vaut
les prévenir au début ensuite leur
expliquer s'il y a des alternatives à ça
ou pas et si oui lesquels elles sont en
fait pour qu'il puisse élaborer d'une
part une vision de ce qu'ils vont tenir
et ensuite c'est d'y arriver
et donc on nous en intervient pas
directement auprès du Comité économique
moi je conseille mes clients ensuite je
les laisse parce que c'est des adultes
responsables faire leur propre
négociation
et après là il y a un paramètre qui est
un contrôlable c'est la qualité du
négociateur je suis pas responsable du
sujet c'est que je pense que de même
situation faite par deux personnes
différentes aboutissent pas au même
résultat ça c'est ma vision personnelle
du sujet après sur pour revenir à votre
point
est-ce que ça ça peut engendrer des
situations de pénurie
en tout cas ou de moindre accès oui je
le pense oui moi j'ai deux exemples
récents un produit
entrant sur le marché
et en plus un peu inattendu sur sa
conclusion parce que firme française
développement français fait la demande
de clinicien français pour avoir une
solution thérapeutique alors qui est pas
une révolution dans dans les produits
qu'elle contient mais en tout cas dans
sa galénique et son mode de dispensation
c'est pour des enfants donc c'est une
solution pédiatrique dans une situation
où le traitement demande à réveiller son
enfant jeune trois fois par nuit pour
lui faire ingurgiter quelque chose qui
ne préparation hospitalière qui n'a pas
du tout envie de prendre parce que c'est
un goût moi j'ai testé moi je pense que
je serais pas très compliant au sujet
donc ça industriel en fait fait un
développement fait des études des mondes
que sa solution
est intéressante d'un point de vue
innovation duquel
et ça reste un point d'interrogation
pour moi en conclusion de négociation on
arrive à un point de proposition du
Comité et qui sont liées à ces critères
de fixation du prix qui sont des
critères publics et ceux de la corcare
qui sont en dessous du prix de revient
industriel
donc là effectivement
la question de lancer un produit qui va
vous coûter de l'argent à chaque botte
que vous allez vendre elle est un peu
compliqué quand même et là on parle pas
de produits à
5000 euros par mois on parle de produits
de coût de traitement à 5 7000 euros par
an
et
le comité mais à raison par rapport en
fait aux éléments dont il a disposition
il dit oui mais le critère industriel
n'est pas un critère de fixation du prix
petite modulation avec
l'article 65 quand même du PLFSS ça
reste marginal quand même oui
c'est pas prévu marginal dans la loi ça
reste marginale
[Musique]
c'est que le comité dirait même si on
arrive au point de revient industriel
ensuite moi je ne suis pas garant d'une
quelconque marche que vous devez
réaliser
et donc oui effectivement même si on
arrive au point de revient industriel
plus ça marche de distribution une
entreprise qui fait 5 ou 10 ans de
recherche pour arriver à mettre sur le
marché un produit qui lui
potentiellement lui coûte marginalement
de l'argent
c'est une situation compliquée elles
sont pas très fréquentes mais elles
existent ces situations
et à l'inverse moi j'ai rencontré une
situation où on un laboratoire un
produit qui est un produit de
prescription réglé il fait appel à des
façonniers français ont un qui est très
dépendant en fait de ce produit se
retrouve dans une situation où
l'augmentation de la cascade des prix de
production coût des matières premières
amène à avoir un prix de revient par
unité qui est au-dessus de son prix
régulier et pose la question au comité
de est-ce qu'on peut se décontraindre en
fait de ce prix régulé l'augmenter pour
assurer une pérennité la réponse du
comité parce que ces règles sont faites
ainsi c'est maintenant que vous avez des
comparateurs
donc on ne peut pas renégocier
la résultante c'est qu'il y a mise en
péril au moins dans des façonniers mais
ça on n'y peut rien parce que quoi qu'il
arrive que l'industriel fasse le choix
de maintenir ce produit ou de le dé
rembourser il y aura un impact sur les
volumes donc il y aura un impact sur la
production
et donc il y a des fois mais moi je
critique pas le travail du comité je dis
juste qu'il a des fois des règles qui ne
lui permettent pas en fait de prendre en
compte des éléments qui à certains
moments permettraient de décontracter un
peu ce type de discussion
tout à fait après il y a des objectifs à
gérer entre la transparence la
reproductibilité
des relations contractuelles et ne pas
donner le sentiment que
l'essentiel de la négociation se fait
qu'elles sur quelque chose qui n'est pas
de référence quoi donc c'est un peu ça
le sujet il y a c'est à dire qu'il y a
les deux les deux dans le premier
exemple que j'évoquais
moi je trouve quand même un peu étonnant
sachant qu'il y a un membre de quoi il a
déjà présenté au niveau du comité
économique la DGCCRF aussi qu'on arrive
une finie à faire une proposition qui
soit en dessous d'un prix de revient
industriel qui sur lequel qui a été
documenté
me laisse un peu perplexe alors ce
produit rassurez-vous en fait il
continue à être à être distribué sur le
marché grâce à une autorisation d'accès
précoce qui a été maintenu et qui a été
une solution qui était trouvée sorte de
rustine je passe mettre d'accord il y a
ce dispositif vous en avez bénéficié on
continue à vous en faire bénéficier sa
régulation est moins pénalisante que
celle qui aurait été la
commercialisation parce que pour
l'affirme c'est pérenne en termes de
vision et d'investissement pour le futur
et pour son directeur financier je suis
pas très sûr
on se focalise beaucoup sur les API et
moi sur les formes galéniques par
exemple qui pourtant peuvent être de
l'innovation et c'est un vrai sujet quoi
surtout si elle permet effectivement de
l'observance d'un traitement qui ne
l'est pas c'est ça l'observant c'est un
élément qui apprend en compte dans
l'ASMR on est d'accord monsieur Clément
alors j'ai évoqué précédemment nos
travaux et notre accompagnement d'un
certain nombre d'acteurs de l'industrie
pharmaceutiques sur les produits
innovants et donc à ce titre on
intervient souvent dans des
problématiques de stratégie de lancement
ou d'accompagnement au lancement
la problématique d'accès ou de prix
est une des problématiques parmi
d'autres des considérations marketing
des considérations d'affaires médicales
des circonstitutions de supply voilà
la plupart de cet accompagnement se fait
auprès des équipes globales
et donc la considération
franco-française est souvent une parmi
tant d'autres et je vous rappelle que le
poids de la France dans le marché
mondial de la suite de riz de
l'industrie pharmaceutique et uniquement
de 3 %
et donc nous ne sommes pas directement
impliqués dans des problématiques
spécifiques et techniques de fixation
des prix ou de négociation avec le CEPS
ou comme on ne l'est pas avec lilvig en
Allemagne ou la Nice en Angleterre
par contre nous prenons en considération
c'est dynamique de prix pour aligner les
timings et les séquences de lancement
reconnaître cette histoire de référence
pricing qui peut exister au niveau
européen et qui peut jouer dans les
séquences de lancement etc voilà le je
dirais le sujet le plus proche qu'on a
de
la problématique de fixation des prix et
de négociation
moi j'ai noté deux questions madame à la
deuxième qui était sur la à ton travail
sur la fixation de prix ou des éléments
de négociation là
non je ne pense pas à ma connaissance
non nous n'avons pas été impliqué sur
des éléments liés à des prix de
médicaments
sur votre première question qui était
sur les stocks
si j'ai bien compris là oui nous avons
nous avons des travaux en cours
précisément autour de et qui sont liés
en fait
entre autres pénurie et aux ruptures
qu'on a pu constater et qui sont
également liés aux conséquences de la
crise covid ou un certain nombre
d'industriels et en l'occurrence un
client s'est rendu compte de la
complexité de sa chaîne
d'approvisionnement du manque de
transparence qui pouvait exister et du
manque de solidité potentiellement dans
certains nombres d'éléments et on nous a
demandé d'aider à accompagner à rendre
cette chaîne d'approvisionnement plus
robuste avec un objectif très important
qui est de diminuer les les ruptures et
les pénuries parce que celles-ci ont un
coût important et d'augmenter le niveau
de service à destination de ses clients
et à destination de ces des patients
donc sur ce sujet là oui nous avons une
nous avons un projet
juste pour pour comprendre donc on ne
sait pas focaliser sur les aspects de
stock on s'est focalisé vraiment sur les
aspects de bout en bout de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement donc comment est-ce
que par exemple on utilise des outils
digitaux ou analytiques ou de la donnée
on ira beaucoup mieux anticiper des
évolutions de demandes potentielles sur
des produits qui sont très différents et
ensuite comment est-ce que on revient en
arrière de manière à avoir une chaîne
d'approvisionnement la plus fluide
jusqu'au site de production donc on
accompagne des équipes de manière très
opérationnelle à mettre en place un
certain nombre de d'outils de systèmes
qui permettent de fluidifier de rendre
plus solides cette chaîne
d'approvisionnement avec encore une fois
l'objectif de
de mettre à disposition des patients les
produits en temps et en heure et en
volume nécessaire
donc ça signifie que c'est un travail
qui peut donc qui va aboutir et donc qui
est c'est pas que pensez-vous du fait
que on mette en place ce travail pour
une liste limitative de médicaments au
plan européen et français de façon à
sécuriser
l'arrivée de médicaments qui sont dit
critiques c'est à dire à la fois à fort
risque de pénurie de façon structurelle
ou conjoncturelle mais aussi qui ont un
service médical rendu tel que ils sont
essentiels et que toute pénurie et
préjudiciable du point de la santé
publique je pense que c'est un élément
critique et important qui peut être
effectivement pris en compte par les
industriels tout à fait
donc sur la question des stocks sur le
la question du du médicament
et on mentionné tout à l'heure les
hôpitaux on a eu l'occasion de
travailler mais de manière je dirais
très
spécifique avec des acteurs hospitaliers
quand on intervient par exemple dans des
blocs opératoires ou dans une unité de
soins sur la bonne adéquation des stocks
déportés de manière à s'assurer que les
personnels voilà et ce qu'il faut etc
donc je pense qu'on est assez loin de ce
qui nous de ce qui nous occupe donc ça
c'est premièrement j'ai pas mémoire mais
je pourrais encore une fois vérifier si
on a été
travaillé sur des logiques des stocks
plus larges au niveau d'un hôpital mais
encore une fois je suis pas sûr que ce
soit ça qui m'occupe du côté vraiment
industriel
etc
là je ne sais pas à ma connaissance j'ai
pas identifié encore une fois dans la
liste de projets qu'on est en train
d'assembler de sujets mais mais on vous
fera parvenir cette liste là
en fin de semaine
on verra si si effectivement il y a des
choses mais à ma connaissance il n'y en
a pas voilà pour ce qui est des aspects
de prix
donc effectivement mes collègues
accompagnent et je reprendrai à peu près
les termes que Monsieur Plantevin a
utilisé accompagne des stratégies de
produits
souvent à l'échelon global
et le plus souvent sur des problèmes
globales
et donc je ne sais pas dans quelle
mesure le prix est vraiment une question
spécifique sur laquelle on s'interroge
et donc ça éventuellement dans le cas
d'une stratégie globale c'est
potentiellement le cas
bien sûr après si vous voulez sur
l'aspect de stratégie de fixation du
prix etc je suis pas sûr je ne sais pas
dans quelle mesure on rentre vraiment
sur ces considérations là et encore une
fois comme les et Monsieur Plantevin on
est on est le plus souvent sur les
premiers globales et donc la France
représente
qu'un élément limité de du périmètre et
enfin on n'a pas d'intervention directe
auprès du CPS et on ne pas
d'intervention directe dans ce type de
négociation ça fait partie des je dirais
des règles qu'on se fixe de ne pas
intervenir directement dans ce type de
et donc pour compléter je pense que je
rejoins que disent mes collègues le les
travaux qu'on mène dans les lancements
de nouveaux produits sont des lancements
qui consistent à déterminer les
conditions de succès de l'entrée de ces
produits dans les dans les différentes
géographies de manière généralement
globale
le prix est naturellement un des
éléments clés d'un modèle économique
malgré tous les travaux
cette expertise c'est une expertise
assez spécifique qui nécessite une vraie
connaissance locale de la réalité
réglementaire de ces prix nos travaux
consistent plutôt à déterminer tous les
facteurs de risque ou les facteurs de
succès de lancement de ces produits donc
on est moins amené à travailler de
manière spécifique sur sur les sujets
locaux on n'a pas naturellement
d'intervention en direct en direct avec
avec le CEPS néanmoins sur le deuxième
question qui est sur la stabilisation
des chaînes d'approvisionnement
travaillant naturellement avec
l'ensemble de l'écosystème on a noté
cette dégradation avant le covid déjà et
après le covid
sur ces conditions de disponibilité de
matière sur certains choix stratégiques
qui ont été faits par des fournisseurs
employés vous mentionnez les principes
actifs
naturellement la crise a continué à
renforcer la complexité mais elle était
déjà prégnante avant et donc aujourd'hui
là où je rejoins mes mes collègues c'est
que le ces enjeux de disponibilité de
lutte contre les ruptures
d'approvisionnement sont deviennent des
sujets majeurs pour les laboratoires et
les industriels dans la mesure où en
fait c'est des situations qui pénalisent
tout le monde le patient d'abord mais
aussi ces industriels qui ont pas la
possibilité de venir un livret en or et
qui est derrière son susceptible d'être
pénalisé
ça signifie quand même que dans
toutes vos interpellations vous utilisez
des comparateurs de prix du médicament
de pays API
spécifiquement non par contre la
fixation d'un généralement lorsqu'on
fait des lancements de produits il y a
des comparatifs qui sont faits pas payer
par pays mais des comparatifs qui sont
faits par rapport à des molécules qui
peuvent être similaires pour avoir une
idée de ce que pourrait être l'ordre de
grandeur d'un prix
nous témoigne du fait que le prix du
médicament en France serait ou est en
tout cas ça dépend
c'est comme le fût du canon n'est ce pas
et donc en fait
serait inférieur pour la plupart des
médicaments matures et en fait c'est un
des éléments d'arbitrage pour distribuer
ou non ou dimensionner la taille des
stocks qui sont envoyés qui sont
destinés à la France en situation de
tension même avant la pénurie voilà donc
est-ce que c'est ces éléments là sont
des éléments sur lesquels on vous
interpelle pour justifier d'un nouvel de
la création d'un nouveau médicament
est-ce que la France est considérée
comme aidante pour les thérapies
innovantes du point de vue financier ou
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres pays qui sont
réputés pour l'être plus ça fait partie
des éléments j'imagine quand même
[Musique]
je crois que le cirque on évoquait
précédemment et un atout indéniable de
la France pour attirer un certain nombre
d'investissements moins sur des outils
industriels et de production mais plus
sur l'innovation
que ce soit le développement
des nouvelles technologies absolument
je partage après ou le cire peut être un
petit peu
[Musique]
ambiguë je pense qu'il est très
intéressant pour que ceux qui sont déjà
présents qui ont déjà en fait fait un
investissement et veulent le compléter
est-ce qu'il est lisible en fait pour
ceux qui voudraient faire une décision
d'arbitrage sur un endroit sur un autre
je suis pas très sûr après sur la
question des prix sur la question des
prix internationaux effectivement en
termes d'innovation
avec l'accord cadre on a une garantie de
prix européen donc la question se pose
beaucoup moins sur les produits matures
l'exemple que j'évoquais préalablement
oui effectivement il y a un problème qui
se pose c'est quand le produit en
question son prix deux fois inférieur en
France à tous les autres marchés
européens
et donc en plus de perdre de l'argent
l'industrielle est confronté au problème
de d'exportation parallèle tous les
stocks qui reçoit alors je suis pas un
spécialiste de la distribution mais je
sais pas si c'est au niveau des
grossistes au niveau des répartiteurs il
y en a un flux qui repart vers
l'étranger parce qu'en fait le prix la
différence de prix entre la France et
l'étranger permet de faire une marche
potentielle que ne fait pas
l'industrielle donc ça c'est que dans le
circuit de distribution mais oui
effectivement ça peut être un frein
majeur à partir du moment où on sait que
si on a une quantité limitée d'un
produit parce qu'il y a des problèmes de
prod c'est plus rentable de les fournir
un marché
qui rapporte de l'argent par rapport à
un marché qui nous rapporte pas c'est
juste une décision de d'hyper
rationalité de gestion en entreprise en
fait et sur les produits nature oui je
pense qu'il y a des sujets
oui quelques précisions encore peut-être
que sur
iggia quand on les a auditionnés ils
nous ont quand même dit que les prix
étaient assez visibles à fixation des
prix donc est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça et je vais je vais comme le
temps tourne je vais être amené à poser
la dernière question les deux dernières
questions à un moment donné donc vous
avez dit que les uns les autres il y
avait pas vous aviez vos conseils n'avez
pas entraîné des délocalisations
partielles de technologie et des
productions pour de motifs déficience
parce que j'avais reprécisé ma question
mais je vois quand même et notamment
issue des travaux de BCG
au niveau de des décisions stratégiques
de Sanofi donc vous avez conseillé et
notamment concernant un plan de
sauvegarde de l'emploi
et bien vous auriez travaillé sur la
rationalisation du nombre de produits
distribués par le groupe 300 familles de
produits 23000 références et là c'est un
lien direct avec les pénuries
médicaments parce que c'est à partir du
moment où vos conseils entraînent des
suppressions de postes et donc un
affaiblissement on va dire de la
production vous comprendrez bien qu'il y
a une incidence monsieur vient spa sur
les les pénuries de médicaments futurs
donc j'aimerais avoir vous concernant
une réponse précise et une réponse aussi
précise au niveau de mackinsey puisque
je vois que sur la période 2015-2019
c'est le cabinet conseil McKinsey qui a
pris la relève donc est-ce que vous avez
été dans les mêmes logiques que votre
confrère si je puis dire enfin ma
dernière question s'adresse à tout le
monde c'est sur le modèle économique du
médicament innovant on voit pour aller
vite que Big Pharma
à une une tactique finalement où il va
préférer favoriser le rachat de startup
pour pouvoir profiter en fait de niche
et pour avoir moins de frais dans
moins de frais dans la dans tout ce qui
est recherche
il va prendre en quelque sorte le
produit enfin l'innovation telle qu'elle
a été faite par ces startups et ensuite
donc une fois que l'innovation est faite
ils vont ils vont
se charger du reste donc je voudrais
savoir si les uns et les autres vous
êtes dans cette dans cette logique
est-ce que vous avez conseillé un
certain nombre d'industriels pour aller
effectivement vers cette logique
économique qui apparaît comme plus
rentable et qui en même temps privilégie
des médicaments innovants qui sont
utiles mais qui sont très onéreux
et parfois qui peuvent couper l'herbe
sous pied à des médicaments matures
et la rationalisation je crois des de
portefeuilles de produits sur le PSE
effectivement nous avons travaillé sur
un à la mise en oeuvre d'un PSA en 2019
je n'étais pas moi-même impliqué sur la
sur la mise en oeuvre de ce de ce PSE
donc je pourrais pas vous dire
exactement
ni ce qu'on a fait précisément ce que je
sais c'est que on a aidé à la mise en
œuvre à la mise en forme d'un certain
nombre d'éléments dans le cadre de ce
PSE et de décision qui avait été prise
par Sanofi
sur le
et comme l'a dit la Présidente c'est
tout à fait normal que vous n'ayez pas
toutes les réponses mais par contre sur
cette question précise qu'il y a des
incidences par rapport à la production
de médicaments comme pour les autres
questions d'ailleurs on vous demande de
nous faire des réponses écrites oui bien
sûr je l'ai noté sur même chose je vous
ferai une réponse écrite précise sur la
rationalisation des produits parce que
même chose c'est pas quelque chose dont
j'ai le souvenir et je ne suis pas sûr
que ce soit lié par ailleurs à ce à ce
PSE ma seule observation personnelle
c'est pour avoir travaillé sur des
réflexions autour de la rationalisation
de portefeuille c'est que la
rationalisation de portefeuille peut
permettre justement la réduction des
pénuries parce qu'on ne diminue pas
nécessairement le nombre de produits
mais on peut diminuer des familles de
référence au sein d'un même produit et
donc un des problèmes auxquels la
plupart des industriels sont confrontées
c'est la multiplication des références
sur un marché mais aussi de manière
globale et donc des portefeuilles
extrêmement complexes pas simplement en
termes de produits mais surtout en
termes de référence et donc un des
objectifs c'est de se dire qu'on va
diminuer le nombre de références de
manière à être beaucoup plus capable de
les produire et de les ensuite de les
distribuer au patients donc je peux pas
répondre sur le fond précisément sur la
question que vous me posez mais avec mon
œil d'expert et pour avoir participé à
un certain nombre de discussions sur ce
sujet là j'aurais aussi tendance à dire
que la la décomplexification d'un
portefeuille peut avoir des effets
extrêmement bénéfiques si je penchaîner
si vous voulez sur le sur votre question
sur le sur la recherche moi je dirais
que le
[Musique]
là c'est une industrie
ou effectivement je crois que les
statistiques disent que 60 70 % des
médicaments ont lancé viennent de
biotech de petite taille c'est une
industrie qui est très ouverte sur
l'innovation externe parce que un des
éléments et que innover dans des plus
petites structures et parfois plus plus
facile ou en tout cas ça c'est montré
comme étant plus facile ce que je dirais
c'est que en sans avoir travaillé
directement sur ce sujet là au cours des
dernières années en tout cas même chose
dans les discussions qu'on a pu avoir
avec un certain nombre de nos clients
faire de l'innovation externe ne veut
pas dire diminuer l'innovation interne
au contraire je pense que ce qui est
très important pour rattraper sur un
certain nombre d'acquisition par exemple
c'est qu'en interne il faut absolument
des compétences de manière à être
capable d'évaluer la science qui
provient de l'extérieur et que les choix
scientifiques au moment de ces
acquisitions ou ensuite au moment du
développement des des produits qui
peuvent être achetés ou bien la SNC
puisse être fait de manière très très
efficace donc même chose je n'opposerai
pas nécessairement le fait que
l'innovation soit externe avec des
pertes de compétences ou des pertes de
souveraineté je pense qu'il existe une
complémentarité forte en travaux des une
recherche interne forte et en même temps
en allant chercher une innovation
qu'elle soit interne ou bien ou bien
externe
écoutez ne servant pas Sanofi je n'ai
pas les informations donc je ne sais pas
le travail qu'on a qu'on aurait pu faire
ensuite de celui de BCG sur la
rationalisation du portefeuille donc je
on va vous apporter des éléments
complémentaires évidemment par écrit
et sur cette question effectivement du
modèle d'innovation
et de bascule d'une innovation fortement
interne une part d'innovation très
externe
il me semble que
l'industrie pharmaceutique sur les 50 ou
60 dernières années a été une industrie
qui s'est basée sur l'innovation ça fait
partie de son modèle je dirais de
développement et de création de valeur
cœur
première élément deuxième élément on a
aujourd'hui une multiplication des axes
d'innovations et et donc en fait des
sources d'innovations qui viennent de
plus en plus effectivement de petites
entités agiles de lien avec le tissu
académique et les hôpitaux on n'a pas
parlé mais qui est une source
d'innovation extrêmement forte et je
pense que le fait que l'industrie change
un peu de modèle de manière à au fond
mettre à disposition sa capacité à
amener ses innovations jusqu'au marché à
travers les développements clinique etc
et ce qui a permis d'ailleurs
d'accélérer le rythme d'innovation des
dernières années où on était passé à la
fin des années 90 début d'année 2000
avec un nombre d'innovation
thérapeutique qui avait fortement baissé
on a de nouveau une nouvelle vague
d'innovation qui qui amène avec des
bénéfices réels pour les patients on
peut penser à l'immunothérapie juste
comme ça et donc cette évolution du
modèle me semble-t-il a été a été
intéressant du point de vue de
l'innovation qui a été apporté pour les
patients
effectivement sur la partie sur la
partie rechercher développement je pense
qu'il faut accepter cette évolution de
modèle dans la mesure où elle est malgré
tout assez déluctable je reviens sur ce
qu'on a vu en innovation dans un
laboratoire fantastique à 10-15 ans il y
a eu il y a eu un certain nombre de de
[Musique]
projets qui ont pas fonctionné parce que
je pense qu'effectivement c'est
compliqué de maintenir parfois
l'innovation dans des grandes structures
et que cette synergie qu'on a vu
apparaître entre des structures plus
petites
qui avaient la possibilité de d'aller
parfois plus vite ou d'être plus
spécialisé spécialisés de secteur qui
deviennent de plus en plus compliqué
technique et scientifiques
arrive à porter quand même une partie de
fruits
moi je pense que le modèle malgré tout
est pas encore optimisé aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui la
difficulté à laquelle vous vous
confrontez c'est que vous avez ont
mentionné la recherche académique je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de
choses à faire pour soutenir ce
transfert entre la recherche académique
et sa capacité à venir se transformer en
innovation
pour continuer à créer de la valeur sur
le territoire français et là souvent
quand on accompagne des startups ou des
petits structures il y a ce qu'on
appelle cette vallée de la mort c'est à
dire c'est complexité à sortir du monde
de la recherche et à venir transformer
l'économiquement une idée en innovation
qui fonctionne et je pense que là-dessus
il y a certainement des choses
intéressantes à faire qui de la
responsabilité de l'ensemble de
l'écosystèmes pour construire la filière
pour faciliter la mise à disposition de
ressources et compétences ça je pense
que c'est un élément intéressant
du coup je n'opposerai pas forcément
cette innovation ouverte à au modèle
aujourd'hui de l'innovation côté
rechercher développement je continue
à conseiller des clients qui
effectivement conduit d'investir de
manière très significative dans
l'innovation c'est juste que la
complexité croissante de ces domaines
scientifiques et techniques fait qu'à un
moment vous êtes vous devez avoir des
choix en fait tout simplement
je suis totalement aligné avec mes
confrères je rajouterais peut-être deux
trois choses le modèle économique a pas
fondamentalement changé les laboratoires
dans les années 2000 dépend des pensées
à peu près 20% de leur structure de
coûts en innovation il continue à
dépenser 20% si ce n'est plus en
innovation pour ceux qui sont dans le
cœur de business model est vraiment
l'innovation
l'innovation est ouverte qu'évoquée
monsieur wirsbah c'est pas forcément
racheter des startups il y a énormément
de partenariats en fait entre des
biotech et des grosses pharmas dont un
certain nombre de biotech françaises
prometteuses qui sont activement en
partenariat aujourd'hui en
codéveloppement de produits très
prometteurs avec des Big Pharma et qui
vont les accompagner à se développer
avec une volonté à un moment de
s'assumer en tant que Pharma et de
pouvoir vivre tout seul
et puis le dernier point que je dirais
c'est dans les dans le budget de R&D ou
dans le développement de dans le coup de
développement d'un produit en fait 80%
de ce coup est en phase 3 donc la phase
vraiment la dernière phase de
développement
ce que généralement apporte la biotech
soit en partenariat soit en achat c'est
les idées en amont et donc le Big Pharma
prend le risque de développement et de
succès technologique et souvent
exposé financièrement à ce risque ce qui
explique d'ailleurs qui continue à
développer à dépenser 20% de son budget
dans le développement de ces produits et
de ses idées innovantes
sur le point de la lisibilité des prix
parce que ça faisait partie de votre
question
alors oui pour des experts les prix sont
assez visibles c'est-à-dire que essayer
de comprendre avec un Data package
clinique ce qu'on va pouvoir obtenir
comme évaluation en transparence et
comment ça va se répercuter en histoire
monétaire qui a un prix quand vous êtes
très immergé dans le dans le paradigme
français oui c'est visible pour un
industriel américain ou étranger pas
vraiment et des fois c'est très
surprenant en fait et jamais dans le bon
sens
après pour ce qui est du effectivement
ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui c'est que
il y a beaucoup de nichage de produits
c'est-à-dire qu'on est beaucoup sur la
pathologie orpheline des très petits
effectifs
et c'est aussi bien un souhait qu'on a
eu dans les années 2000 qui était
favoriser la recherche et le
développement dans les maladies
orphelines ça quand même été un cheval
de bataille mondial pas que européen
mais aussi américain et les fruits en
ressortent aujourd'hui en fait
[Musique]
après ce qui est une volonté spécifique
de snicher je pense surtout qu'il y a
une volonté spécifique d'aller où là où
il y a un besoin et les besoins ils sont
de plus en plus sur des niches
relativement étroites en fait
si vous prenez la cancéro vous pouvez
l'exemple du cancer du sein quand vous
regardez le nombre de gradients auquel
il faut répondre effectivement vous
arrivez à déniche cancer du sein ça veut
pas dire grand chose en fait il y a tout
il y a une multiplicité en fait de cible
et de réponse différente pour pour y
arriver et donc oui ça crée en fait des
niches spécifiques de recherche qui
donne l'impression potentiellement que
il y a une volonté je pense qu'il y a
surtout une obligation de recherche pour
arriver à un résultat
c'est mon opinion en tout cas
ce qui est certain c'est que le prix n'a
pas de commune mesure il y a plutôt
tendance à s'envoler ces dernières
années qu'à diminué sur sur l'innovation
on a beau être sur des questions de
niche on est très clairement dans une
logique exponentielle à la limite du
raisonnable et en tout cas avec la
certitude que les pouvoirs publics et
donc le financement public de la santé
parce qu'il y a une part privée une part
ne pourra pas assumer à un moment les
politiques de santé publique quoi c'est
clair et donc c'est un vrai sujet et à
partir du moment il y a des choix quand
même d'afficher un certain nombre de
prix qui sont
comment dire audacieux et complètement
décorrélés finalement de de
la réalité en matière d'innovation parce
qu'on est quand même sur des éléments
d'innovation qui sont à peu près
identifiants en ce moment la vraie
innovation de rupture ça a été la RN
messager par exemple parce que ça on
n'avait pas mais il y a des innovations
on voit que ça voilà donc c'est la
nouvelle formule nous mais on voit bien
qu'on est quand même sur des choses
choses qui sont déjà plus normées et
d'ailleurs en termes de process de
fabrication on devrait pouvoir commencer
à standardiser un peu plus les choses et
donc attirer le prix un peu vers le bas
du coup de la fabrication donc je veux
dire de la question l'innovation et de
la niche certes on entend bien mais dans
les faits il y a quand même un moment
une réflexion à avoir et à mettre de la
raison dans ce qui devient complètement
déraisonnable
je peux me permettre de préciser parce
que je constate le sujet mais il y a une
très grosse différence entre le prix
liste et le prix net quand j'ai très
grosse elle peut être énorme vraiment
énorme et l'innovation marginale elle
est jamais récompensée par plus cher en
termes de net
elle peut avoir une liberté en termes de
liste parce qu'en fait l'accord 4 fait
que ça peut être une asmr4 qui peut
avoir un accès à un prix européen donc
vous avez l'impression qu'il y a une
invation au niveau du list mais au
niveau du net il y a aucune récompense
mais ça c'est une réalité qui n'est pas
visible ce qui fait qu'on traite cette
question dans le cadre des pénurie de
médicaments c'est que la tentation est
grande à partir du moment où les prix
s'envolent de façon complètement
incroyable enfin inimaginable
à un moment les médicaments mature sont
la variable d'ajustement des choix
stratégiques et très clairement il y a
des ces choix là font défaut même dans
la prise en charge de certains cancers
et avec des anticancéreux essentiels
pour certains cancers je pense à
certaines leucémies il y a des moments
médicament pénurie si on l'a pas on peut
pas traiter et donc c'est donc c'est
c'est pour ça que les deux aspects sont
quand même très très liés
en fait pour moi ça fait plus de 25 ans
que je fais du conseil dans
ce sur de la négociation et de
l'évaluation en fait il y a une limite
basse qui a jamais été fixée
c'est-à-dire que la limite basse de des
cascades d'un prix sur un élément en
fait de minimum de rentabilité
acceptable cette limite elle a jamais
été fixée le comité vous dira en fait
moi je j'essaye de le prendre en compte
mais je peux pas vraiment ils ont pas
tort c'est pas dans leurs critères
alors nous on pourrait se dire
effectivement vu que la DGCCRF siège de
vraiment donner peut-être lever le doigt
et dire pris en dessous du péris c'est
compliqué mais ce raisonnement il n'est
jamais fait
donc le comité joue avec les règles
qu'il a à sa disposition et il y a
effectivement des effets collatéraux
voilà
pour revenir à la question d'origine du
départ de cet échange je vous remercie
beaucoup nous vous ferons parvenir donc
un certain nombre de questions avec le
souhait d'avoir les réponses écrites
avant le rendu du rapport voilà donc le
plus tôt possible pour dire les choses
voilà pour mettre un délai assez serré
ne soyez pas surpris et merci beaucoup
de cet échange